Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to 'I'm Still Here'. Now-I don't know a lot about this game-Oh!
"Ahh. Finally moving into my new place. A chance to start a new life."
"The landlord seemed a little weird about this place, but I don't have time to worry about that."
"I need to finish putting those books away."
Okay, alright. What books are we talking about here? The-oh. *chuckling* Oh-ho-ho!
Okay, OH!
Now, I suspected that this was a type of horror game, but it seems awfully peaceful to be that, and I have to
meticulously put books away.
I mean- I'm down with it! Don't get me wrong,
I'm down with it,
but I just-I didn't know that this was going to be the primary part of the gameplay.
I have a funny feeling that it's about to turn horrifying and/or weird before the end of this.
Almost done, a little more. I don't have a lot-ooh..
"What the heck? Why are my books moving?"
"Yeah, I had a funny feeling about this. I need to figure out what's going on."
"I should ask the internet-" *starts chuckling* THAAT'S WITH ALL MY PROBLEMS!
I need to ask the internet immediately! HELLO! WAHOO!
Uh-"Why don't I-Why don't my..
book-*starts chuckling again* Wha- what? "WHY DON'T MY
PARENTS WANNA TALK TO ME?!"
"You should try calling your parents to make sure they aren't dead." Well, that's sad, I guess.
Alright. "Why don't my bathroom lights work?" "Check the breaker wires. One of them might be loose."
"Why don't my stuffs stay-'' *talks with a funny accent* "WHY DON'T MY STUFFS STAY STILLL?! All my furniture and stuff keeps moving around on its own!"
"You got ghosts bro! You need to perform an exorcism."  Well snap-OOOH GOD!
OH! I THINK I HAVE GHOSTS!
I'm pretty a hundred percent sure that this might be the workings of ghosts. Uhh-
Yeah, definitely ghosts. Probably that. I should ask the internet how to get rid of these ghosts, okay.
"I.. have.. a
...painful lump in armpit." "There's a good chance you have an infection.
You should make sure you wash it  thoroughly and shave it carefully. There's also a likelihood it could be cancer."
Huh. "I have a problem with stuff moving by itself."
"I have a ghost I wanna piss off."
"When I wanna annoy my sister, I flip the light switch over and over. Gets her every time."
"Hmmm... This sounds promising." *chuckles*
"I should flip my lights on and off to annoy the ghost!"
Okay, I'll do that! I don't know how I'm gonna do that. How about this-
HEY GHOST! HEY GHOST BITCH!
HEY, GET SOME OF THIS! *makes odd noises while flipping the light switch*
"Cut that out dude! Jeez."
"Who said that? Get out of my house!"
"No, way, this is my house! Stop being such a jerk." "This is my house now. You must be dead." "Oh, wow this is heavy...
my spirit must be stuck here because my body still needs to be put to rest." "That makes sense to me!"
"Will you help me find my body then?" OH-
"Sure, if it'll get you to leave me alone." I think I need to call the police about this one,
there's a dead body in my apartment! That seems bad-"I will find your body and put you to rest."
Okayy... *chuckles a little* "Can I-" "How do I...
...printscreen using mac?" "Delete my internet history?" "You can't, destroy the laptop."
"I know if I'm being haunted?", "Keep things from moving?'', "Get rid of a ghost?"
Alrighty then... I guess I need to find the body.. Hello?
Oh, no. Hello? Nope. He-Hel-Hello?
HELLOOO!
BODYY!
DEAD BODYY?
DEAD BODYY-Oh.
Hello? Ooo-oh.
What was that?
I DUNNO WHAT I JUST DID BUT I THINK I CAN-Ooh.
Okay.. Hello? Hello-Oh-
"Hey, that's me! You found me!" OH! Oh, you're a fish! "So that's how I died. Wow, this is heavy.
I got shat out by someone.
Well, can you help me move on so I can stop haunting this place?"
"I'll finally put you to rest little buddy."
Oh, I gotta... *starts laughing*
I gotta flush you down! This is like that episode of Dexter's Laboratory! You have to put him to rest!
Oh no, you have to flush him. "I'm free!"
"Rest in peace little buddy. I'll always remember you."
OH THAT'S IT!
WHAT?! "You go on to have a peaceful night and live comfortably in your new apartment,"
"but you can never shake the memory of your little friend. You occasionally take a peek in the toilet and dream finding them there again,"
"but all you find in the bowl is emptiness."
"Occasionally, there's a turd-" *starts laughing* "-if you forgot to flush earlier."
Ah jeez. Ah, screw you-THE END!
Wow. What an astonishing game.
Unlike any I've ever played in my entire life.
OH, A MASTERPIECE, AN INCREDIBLE ADVENTURE! I gotta admit, that was actually kinda fun! It's so cool!
I mean, it's weird... And it is EXACTLY LIKE that episode of Dexter's Laboratory,
where he didn't flush the fish and it haunted him to that day. And then tried to suck his sister down into the toilet.
But that's a whole 'nother story!
So thank you for joining me on this epic adventure. Thank you for helping me put this fish soul to rest.
I think we will all miss Fred the Fish.
But he is resting now..
That ghostly, ghostly fish is swimming in the sewers of peace.
We will always remember Fred!
*fake sniffle* Always...
So anyway,
Thank you everybody so much for watching! Let me know what you think-in fact write a FULL REVIEW
of this incredible adventure down in the comments below.
I'll read each and every one of them.
And I thank you all so much for watching. And as always I will see you...
in the next video...
BUH BYEE!